hey guys welcome to new rock stars I'm
Sam basher and over the past couple
weeks I've been racking my brain trying
to figure out what's gonna happen and
what's in store for Avengers four who's
gonna take on Thanos who are treating
Infinity Gauntlet and fix the universe
are they gonna make us remember everyone
who got turned to dust two maybe a few
people that accidentally inhaled some of
that Ash that would be a weird memory to
keep just don't stand downwind when
you're friends be deleted from the
universe that's all I'm saying
one popular theory is that we will
finally meet a character that has been
teased in the MCU for quite some time
Adam warlock Adam has gone up against
Thanos many times in the comics has a
pretty intimate relationship with one of
the Infinity stones aka the soul stone
and has bumped into the Infinity
Gauntlet 1 or 2 times but who is Adam
warlock what is his relationship to the
soul stone and why could he go up
against Santos and win let's discuss for
the warning of course for infinity war
MC whoo okay let's keep going well he
first appeared in the Fantastic Four
comics in issue 66 and 67 September
October of 1967 AE but at that point he
was just known as him him was an
artificially created human being but a
perfect human being so he obviously has
powers of course hands up rebelling
against the scientists who created him
and made his way out into the universe
we bums to none other than the High
Evolutionary now this character is very
convoluted actually plays a big role in
the origin of Scarlet Witch and
Quicksilver but to some of his character
really quickly he likes to genetically
alter beings in order to create the
perfect being in the perfect world
these creatures are known as new men and
normally there are these animal hybrids
that are genetically altered to behave
and look like people anyhoo the High
Evolutionary actually recruits him to
get a job done form on counter-earth
oh yes counter-earth it is the planet
the High Evolutionary rules where all of
his new men live and actually runs
counter clockwise of Earth on the same
axis do you believe this job the High
Evolutionary gives warlock the soul gem
that's what they call them back then
gems Nutkin stones you get it with the
soul gem and the new name from High
Evolutionary warlock it's a lot easier
to say than him warlock was able to
finish his job and then he you know
screwed her out into the universe once
again but anyways from there he gets the
full name atom war
when she kind of gives himself and teams
up with a number of cosmic hero
specifically though most often Gamora
pip the troll that character I don't
know if we're gonna ever see the movies
but who knows but finally the mad Titan
Thanos yes they have worked together
before
now Adams whole story does get a bit
convoluted because one of his many
over-the-top powers is that he can never
really die like he can die or get
mortally wounded but then he kind of
just forms a cocoon around himself and
he can be reborn at one point he even
spent some time inside of the soul world
when he didn't regenerate that's a
little dimension we saw in the finale of
Avengers infinity war that pool world
with baby Gamora I'm also that's worth
pointing out that one of Adam's main
adversaries in comics besides Thanos is
Magus and this is actually the first
time that Santos and the whole gang team
up to take on Magus now sometimes Negus
is a future version of Adam who has been
corrupted by the soul stone he's got a
little purple hue of course cuz this is
a bad guy but sometimes he's just the
evil incarnate like he's the evil
leached out of Adam and given a form now
on to what his powers are well Adam has
a super-strength flight he can survive
in the vacuum of space energy
manipulation so he can just absorb stuff
and you know shoot it back out but also
he has a mastery of the soul gem which
he usually keeps right up here he does
sometimes show some mystical abilities
and can sometimes restore other people's
health by putting them in their own
cocoons next what is his relationship to
Thanos well during the events of the
Infinity Gauntlet storyline in the
comics it's somewhat similar Adam is
extremely important in mounting the
attack on Thanos to stop him from
killing the universe now after that he
is tasked with creating infinity watch a
group of people who are responsible for
the safety of the infinity gems they're
all spread out between these six
individuals and they keep him safe
besides that instance Adam and Thanos
actually have teamed up a few times in
the comics once even to save the entire
universe as for the MCU introduction for
Adam walk well we thought we were
introduced to him way back in phase 2
yes all the way back then you guys
remember in the post-credits scene for
Thor Ragnarok when we meet the collector
for the first time we can actually see
the cocoon in the background in one of
the cases and in an interview with some
of the people who made this movie they
confirm
it was in fact Adam warlock spooky
however that was later retconned during
the Adam warlock post-credits scene in
guardians a galaxy vol 2 now what we see
Adam warlock pop up in infinity war part
2 well before I shot this video I had a
bunch of different theories as to how he
could have been included however the
Russo brothers have recently been
interviewed and have confirmed that he
will not be appearing in part two of
infinity war whatever they're gonna call
it bit of a bummer I'm gonna be honest I
did delete a bunch of paragraphs but hey
that doesn't mean he'll never pop up in
the MCU I'm guessing he's being saved
for guardians the galaxy vol 3 which is
still cool and he'll most likely be the
main focus of that film could also be a
way to get Gamora back from the dead
since Adam and Gamora have been close in
the comics and they both left the soul
world within the soul gem and returned
to the land of the living with that
tease during the soul world sequence
Infinity Ward that's where I'm guessing
she'll be baby who as for Adams
introduction into the MCU I think it
would be most interesting to really show
his cosmic level abilities and to really
add some stakes
let's have Magus show up as well this
could lead to some very emotionally
heavy story beats but also someone would
be of equal power to Adam you family
that's kind of important sometimes tough
fight him maybe even throwing the new
men in a High Evolutionary into the mix
think about this I know the High
Evolutionary usually is a human but
maybe he's an alien scientists out in
space who's been making human-animal
hybrids it would be a pretty cool visual
that's all I'm saying
maybe even this could tie into Rockets
origins possibly we've never met the
scientists that experimented on him
but anyways I'm getting a little bit of
off track a little bit ahead of myself
also infinity watch wouldn't be the
worst idea either as a storyline for
guardians the galaxy vol 3 seeing
powerful Marvel characters being charged
with protecting the Infinity stones but
this is when I throw it to you guys what
do you guys think about Adam warlock
popping up in the MCU how would you like
to see him be introduced let me know in
the comments down below be sure to like
this video share and subscribe for more
infinity war content and there's other
videos too but you guys seem to be
really eating those up so we're gonna
keep making them
I'm Sam bass you're at Sam bass you're
on Twitter check out my podcast only
stupid answers and I'll see you guys
next time